>> HENLEY: I'm J. R. Henley; I'm the product
developer for Weather Decision Technologies
in Norman, Oklahoma. And we are a Google Maps
API user. Right now we have weather maps using
the Google Flash Maps API. And we have that
embedded in about 250 or 300 newspaper and
television websites.
>> GANSEN: Scott Gansen, I'm a senior software
engineer for Weather Decision Technologies.
I kind of do the nuts and bolts behind the
scene programming that feed these guys data
for the maps.
>> And so it's not your decision to [indistinct]
>> HENLEY: We've been using the JavaScript
API for quire a while, almost since the--since
it was released. And I really wanted the ability
to do the animations that we can do in Flash.
And so, we actually had started down the road
of making our weather products available in
a Flash application. And Google happened to
be the first public release of Flash API.
And so, it really worked out well for us that
we had already--we are familiar with the Google
product and so we ported everything and had
been really happy with it. [pause]
>> GANSEN: Initially I think during the beta
stages it was a little doggy but I think now
it's really performing very nicely I would
say. And from requests all the way through
just regular process or usage and things like
that on a compliance computer. And so, it's
been a great asset.
>> [indistinct]
>> GANSEN: Not that I remember a version.
>> HENLEY: Yeah, it just seems to continually
get better. You know, they'll add enhancements
and improvements. And at the same time we're
learning how to do things better with the
Flash code. And so, it's been a growing process
I think for both Google and our company as
well.
>> And so, enter the feature, and so, what
additional features that Google added to this?
>> HENLEY: Right now we have some problems
with--we load a lot of custom-tile data. And
we would like the ability to determine whether
or not a tile has loaded successfully or maybe
a progress of a tile loading. We'd like to
have something like that built into the API
for both our tiles and for Google Map tiles.
Sometimes with the API the Google Map tiles
themselves have a problem coming through or
something.
>> And where do you get your data?
>> HENLEY: Oh, we actually, oh, all right,
Scott, you go ahead with that one, that's
you.
>> GANSEN: yeah, a lot of it like you said
is like custom tile layers. It's a lot of
what we do or a very dynamic data set such
as radar data over the entire United States.
It changes every five minutes. And so, we,
yeah, we created odds. It's been a very interesting
process. I think we've had three different
iterations on how we actually create the data
and serve it into Google and things. And it's
fun though, it's challenging, that's for sure.
>> And so, what was the biggest challenge
that you've encountered?
>> GANSEN: I'll let you go from there.
>> HENLEY: All right, yeah. Initially the
Google info windows weren't able to--you weren't
able to do custom info windows with the Flash
API. And our clients wanted to have control
over the look and feel of what the info windows
look like. And so, we ended up not using the
Google info windows but we made map markers
that when you would click on them they would
get big and look like an info window but they
were really just big map markers at that point.
>> And [indistinct] what do you see is the
future in map making?
>> GANSEN: There are a couple of things there.
>> HENLEY: I se there--I see a lot of mapping
in the mobile space. You're already seeing
that with Android, you know, with all these
Smart Phones. I think there will be a lot
more GPS integration. There will be a lot
more--and a lot more live data being fed in
maps. And that is actually the project that
I'm working on. It's called the iMap Tracker
and what I'm doing with this is taking live
video feeds from storm chasers in the field
and plotting their location on a Google map.
And you can click on a marker for their vehicle
and it opens a window that will show live
video from their vehicle which is kind interesting.
We've actually seen tornadoes happening in
the Real Time on the Google map which is kind
of fun and exciting.
>> Do you work on that with other agencies?
>> HENLEY: Our offices are right next door
to the National Weather Center. And so, we're
close by. And we have partnered with some,
what do you call it, data something?
>> GANSEN: It's more on the data side then
I'd say the mapping side and the end use of
side.
>> And what's your favorite landing site besides,
you know, Google?
>> GANSEN: Maps.google.com, I guess.
>> HENLEY: You know, I didn't have any answer
for that question.
>> GANSEN: But I knew it.
>> HENLEY: We always go to our own sites.
>> And with the interesting [indistinct] do
you want to share [indistinct] maps API?
>> GANSEN: The maps API itself? Oh, they have
a tile manager and you had to do...
>> HENLEY: Yes, for us--initially, there wasn’t
a custom-tile layer overlay class available
in the Flash API. And so, for us to get animated
radar as--which we're creating in tiles, we
had to basically create a new map layer that
have the Google tiles underneath our pseudo-animated
radar tiles. And getting that all to work
and be really smooth was a pretty big challenge
but we ended up making it through. And about
the time we made it through that then Google
released the class to let do that directly
and so.
>> And so now it all worked out.
>> HENLEY: And so, it worked out, yeah.
>> Well, okay, thanks a lot for your time.
>> HENLEY: Thank you very much.